it's the largest budget ever for the U.S
military but U.S President Joe Biden
says his 842 billion dollar proposal for
defense is badly needed let's be clear
where I stand
I'll not allow the cuts
the needs of the intelligence Community
or our military to help keep us safe
included in Biden's 2024 budget unveiled
on Thursday 6 billion for Ukraine's
fight against Russia and a wish list
full of promises Biden made during his
last presidential campaign money for
Universal Child Care reducing
prescription drug costs and making
college free for lower income Americans
but it's just the first step the budget
has to go to the U.S Congress it
approves all government spending and
there are plenty of lawmakers who say
Biden's budget is Dead on Arrival
Biden's latest budget proposal does
nothing but confirm what we already know
his hopelessly powerless against awoke
socialist left the biggest issue how to
pay for government programs such as
Social Security and Medicare which
provide income and health care for tens
of millions of American seniors I
guarantee you
I will protect Social Security and
Medicare
without any change guaranteed
Biden's solution tax the rich slash tax
cuts for wealthy Americans championed by
former president Donald Trump and raised
corporate taxes to 28 percent while
slapping a 25 percent minimum tax on the
richest one percent of income earners
the White House says the proposed budget
seeks to cut America's deficit by 3
trillion over 10 years President Biden's
budget in its current form has little
chance of passing the
republican-controlled House of
Representatives in Congress but that's
not Biden's only priority he's also
previewing his platform as a 2024
presidential candidate likely to run for
reelection
Kimberly Helk at Al Jazeera the White
House